If you name a specific supplement to increase NK cells, NK cells are natural killer cells.
That's a subtype of white blood cells. So, natural killer cells and T cells are the
subtypes of white blood cells that are essential for killing cancer. So, there's labs that you
could do that you could measure your natural killer cells and you could measure your T cell.
You could measure your lymph-limatic sub-site cells. If there's a Syrex, I think it's a rate 29
or something like that where it's a full panel or a measure in all your lymphocyte
subtypes, do I think that's necessary to do that? No. Have I ordered that very often? No,
unless somebody actually is begging me to do that. Why? Because there isn't like a magic thing you
could do to increase those things. There's no specific supplement that can increase those
things. Even though there are supplements out there in the market, I think Bionics has a NK cell
supplement. I don't know. But I don't remember if it was Bionics or a different supplement that had
a supplement named after that but what was in there was Vitamin C and you don't want to take
that lower dose of Vitamin C as a cancer patient anyhow. So, it's like no. The immune stimulants that
you're doing, you're taking mushrooms. If you're taking mushrooms, if you're taking different
immune stimulants for your cancer, let's say Oregano and Acid Asia and Burberry and Perkiman, those
things are helping with that anyhow. There isn't going to be a specific supplement that's going to
stimulate T cells or natural killer cells. But you can look at what is necessary for your body to
make these subsets of natural killer cells and T cells. And we've talked about this multiple times
before is that these are these subsets of white blood cells are completely dependent upon
protein consumption. So protein consumption is super important to make white blood cells. That's
why I rarely advocate for somebody who has cancer to be on a vegetarian or vegan diet.
Because a vegan vegetarian diet, it's going to be very difficult for you to get adequate protein
consumption. And I know there's people out there that may listen to this video and argue that
well we can I could eat enough mama means in order to, you know, get X amount of grams of protein.
Well, maybe you can, but it's going to be much more difficult for somebody who's dealing with the
chronic disease to eat that amount of vegetarian protein in order to get the grams of protein they
need. And it is recommended that you get that you're eating upwards towards one gram per protein,
per pound of body weight. So if you weigh 125 pounds, you're trying to get 125 grams of protein.
If you eat a chicken breast, you can get 45 grams of protein, but I don't know how you could do that,
you know, it'll eat it without eating some meat. So eating some meat can be beneficial for them.
Eating red meat can also be beneficial for cancer patients if they have anemia, which is another
common issue with cancer patients. You know, your cancer can be growing, it can gobble up,
red blood cells, it can be gobbling up, iron, and you could have low iron stores, you could have
anemia issues. It's very common with cancer. And, you know, you could take iron, but you could be feeding
the cancer with iron. So taking an ornamentated with iron is the way to go. But eating some red meat
can be beneficial in developing white blood cells and developing red blood cells. So
to answer your question, no, there's not a specific nutrient that's going to increase
natural killer cells or T-cells.